police in the Dominican Republic
arrested a second suspect overnight in
connection with the shooting of Red Sox
legend David Ortiz Big Papi it's still
unclear why Ortiz was shot and our
mullet leg is outside the bar where it
happened in Santo Domingo molla what
more do we know today well so far police
have not named this person or indicated
whether this person is in fact the
suspected shooter police have detained
at least five people for questioning
since Sunday's shooting that happened
right here at the dial bar and lounge in
the entertainment district of Santo
Domingo
Ortiz was actually sitting right here on
this patio deck of the dial bar and
lounge when the motorcyclist approached
the gunman hopped off approached Ortiz
and shot him in the back but police are
still investigating whether Ortiz was
the intended target of the shooting the
first suspect was transferred to court
in Santo Domingo yesterday police say
Eddie Garcia was the motorcyclist who
brought the shooter to Ortiz he's
charged and as an accomplice to an
attempted murder but Garcia's lawyer
says that he is a fan of Ortiz and he
did not know what he was about to have
what he was about to take the shooter to
when he picked the shooter up in Boston
Ortiz took his first steps in the
hospital where he is recovering with the
help of his family he underwent a second
exploratory surgery there in Boston and
will stay in intensive care for at least
a few more days to avoid any sort of
internal bleeding and other
complications in a statement
Ortiz's wife Tiffany said that Ortiz is
expected to make a full recovery that he
is resting comfortably and of course she
thanked everyone for the love and
support that the family has received
Anthony mola Lengai in the Dominican
Republic thanks mola